hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday May 9 2020 what's going on
how are ya all right guess what I got a
guest I'm like the other podcasts I have
a guest I've been having guests lately
we got from the let there be talk
podcast and from tomorrow night's Bon
Scott tribute at the [ __ ] Avalon
right across the street from Capitol
Records where all the [ __ ] big hits
were recorded we got Dean Del Rey what's
going on dude yeah man what is happening
what's happening is I'm trying to figure
out where to put this [ __ ] recorder I
know I'm I love watching your process
cuz I always just picture you just just
like what's going on right now record
before I'm ready to start this part of
the charm it's part of the charm you
know broke screen on your phone I love
that yeah I've given up on that I broke
the screen at the [ __ ] Apple Store
and then cuz they weren't helping me
with some other [ __ ] so I was just
throwing [ __ ] into my [ __ ] backpack
and I didn't realize that my phone was
only there and then I was on the road
and I had some bootleg place fix it and
then I don't know what happened then it
just sort of broke again yeah every time
I've thrown it in anger it's never
broken yeah but if I just I don't know I
just sort of set something down then it
because people look at it going Jesus
Christ you throw your phone it's like
well yeah I throw it all the time but it
never breaks it's weird like a fluke
thing so oh man
anyway what the [ __ ] was I gonna tell
you you know I was watching this thing
well let's talk about what we came on
here to promote yeah there's a few
tickets left is this this amazing
[ __ ] show that I still don't think
people understand the level of this show
where it just seems that it's gonna be
like it's gonna be like okay a stand-up
show and then like this dad bands gonna
come out and do their highway to hell I
think they understand I guess they've
seen some clips some people have if you
debating going you should [ __ ] go
because first of all it's a deal
yeah it is is it tick one of the tickets
$40 40 bucks you get to see a killer
stand-up show and then you get to see
half the [ __ ] rock stars that you
grew up watching I feel anyways all
these drummers and everybody coming out
I don't want to name names because you
know people dropping in dropping out
adding on and all of a sudden they're
going on a [ __ ] tour but you know all
these guys yeah through all your years
of being a frontman it's so hard to
schedule because you got your dream list
of people huh
and then they all go yeah I can do it
now if I could've did it like a month
ago I might have got some you know
people getting ready to go on these
tours and stuff but now who knows what
the coronavirus knows torn but you know
what I do love is all of these guys
because it's the Bon Scott thing may
like the love that people have for
arguably one of the greatest front men
of all [ __ ] time and I it's [ __ ]
hilarious because I still watch all of
that [ __ ] I somehow today went down this
rabbit hole on YouTube and I vaguely
remember this contest but MTV had a
contest you win a Lost Weekend with Van
Halen oh yeah I love that little
15-minute thing on that guy saw that yes
great just to get people to Baxter was
1984 yeah the height of the band martial
process and all of that [ __ ] they're
going on tour and who knew this is the
last time the four original guys they
still haven't played since that tour
yeah they do no that's right cuz my god
then he wasn't it yeah forgot it was
it's not you're right so it's never been
that so you figure if that tour wrapped
up in 85 like they have not all for them
have not been on stage together in
thirty five [ __ ] years how sad is
that
such a great band so anyway they this
MTV had a thing as they said back when
they played music they said you know
submit a postcard and you could you
could go on tour for a weekend hang out
with Van Halen yeah so this kid wins it
I'll put a clip out there I'll send a
link I should say for people listening
to this
and you know I thought it's gonna be
like the yeah here's some t-shirts and
some buttons and [ __ ] you know little
group photo and whatever they didn't
they like [ __ ] parted with this kid
oh my god they got him [ __ ] oh they
got a knob oh did oh my god it was a
real last weekend man but what's funny
is you read all the comments in YouTube
on the YouTube page it's just so you
just couldn't you couldn't do it in a
liability the cell phone cameras
everybody like all of these [ __ ] kids
it's a what's cool about the cell phone
cameras is if anything [ __ ] happens
somebody's got video on it yeah we're
like oh my god I saw this bear [ __ ]
you know mauled a [ __ ] guy collecting
trash and then like where's the Vinny
the video somehow shows up right yeah so
that part's cool I mean granted the guy
probably would die in that scenario but
whatever but like the thing that you pay
for is that there's no there's no back
history on that so there's no there's no
like no just a man's and their jobs yeah
yeah you know what I mean but I can't
what what is the word like you could
just you can't sold culture no but you
could like sort of exists without
everybody knowing what the [ __ ] you were
doing all the time the mystique was huge
back then right yeah people they what
people would have to like describe so
what happened where were you level on
all of this [ __ ] [ __ ] now if somebody
won that thing they'd spend half the
weekend videotaping what their
experience with selfies yeah they
wouldn't even realize what they were
doing because they would have the thing
on the whole time yeah and I'm not
[ __ ] on young people because I would
be doing that too oh absolutely
I can't imagine some of the footage I
would've heard [ __ ] that I didn't really
fully experience they gave away John
Kerr the little pink houses MTV gave
away a house they had crazy contests BAM
we're gonna paint the mother pink yeah
yeah yeah that's on little pink ass yeah
you and me so then they gave away a
little pink house in like [ __ ]
Indiana yeah [ __ ] hilarious they they
had some really that was such a great
channel like I'm and it's a shame what
happened to it and it didn't take long
by the end of the
it was already [ __ ] yeah you know why
that came about why they stopped playing
all the videos and all that show no
because they couldn't it was like a
ratings thing the way I heard it was
like because they played this video then
five minutes later they played that
video and people if they didn't like the
song they were changing the channel so
they couldn't get an accurate read of
how you know ratings yeah like it cuz it
wasn't like a TV show they just play it
but it's weird because they can do it
with radio that was the excuse I
remember here right so what they did was
then they had like the real show yeah
they had like a TV shows and [ __ ] and
they had like game shows and uh who the
[ __ ] jay mohr did one early on and
Chris Hardwick did one like hosts Wow
back then oh yeah yeah yeah they were
host Chris Hardwick did one with Jenny
McCarthy I think once that real world
hit that became the blueprint of reality
TV for the for all the way to now once
they had a Huck that Guy'd puck and he
was a lunatic he was the first guy that
showed that if you're the biggest like
annoying person yeah on a reality show
that you're gonna be the star and people
are gonna tune in to watch and it equals
ratings that everything you know it's
funny he brought that [ __ ] up because I
was at breakfast this morning with my
lovely wife and she gave me the sports
section they had this whole [ __ ]
thing on all the top women athletes out
there and sad to say like I I I only
knew I knew the gymnast yeah but I don't
came remember her name I've seen her on
a bunch of things
she's like the greatest gymnast ever I
should know her [ __ ] name I dumped
busy whatever but in oracy new Serena
Williams and there was all of these
other people there was a couple figure
skaters that I knew so the reoccurring
thing was in the article was how they
don't support women's sports the way
they do the men's sport and bla bla bla
bla bla and I saw this thing where I
think it was the female soccer players
we're suing some sort of soccer
organization to pay as much attention to
them as they are the guys and I got this
big [ __ ]
discussion with my wife going that's not
how business works like I know it comes
off as sexist right and not saying there
isn't sexism out there but there's all
kinds of [ __ ] out there you know how it
works is if you're making money that's
it if you got a draw if you're making
[ __ ] money they're gonna swoop in and
try like we first started doing podcast
nobody gave a [ __ ] yeah and all of a
sudden we started making money and then
all these business guys came in they
started [ __ ] throwing advertising and
all of that [ __ ] in there as a stand-up
comedian right my journey I was not the
guy yeah so what I had to do was just
[ __ ] keep slamming against the
[ __ ] wall
until I broke through and I remember
seeing like the Kings of Comedy
right yeah Bernie Mac DL Hughley Steve
Harvey and whom I miss in there the [ __ ]
who's the fourth what's his dirty mac
Steve Harvey DL Hughley and I said
entertainer tonight yep white Hollywood
was not [ __ ] with them so they were
like [ __ ] it let's all do a [ __ ] tour
together we'll go to our own markets
right [ __ ] white people we never fight
we don't [ __ ] need then let's say
they said that but you know yeah and
then all of a sudden they started
selling out arenas in white Hollywood's
like hey move on the rednecks the
redneck tour oh yeah yeah the Hollywood
have lead us out here that's a flood
that's a flyover state I don't give a
[ __ ] about you and your second Amendment
you're probably banging your sister how
they look at [ __ ] rednecks right huh
then they all got together you know
arena started doing arenas and then they
all got their own [ __ ] shows yeah so
- [ __ ] the way to do it's the way to
get something is not to [ __ ] complain
because there's always something to
complain about
yeah the way to do it is to just get
your fanbase going yeah and this is the
thing like what I don't understand okay
I wish there was a woman on this podcast
right now right
that could chime in because I don't get
the way they're trying to go about
getting what they
should get because I believe in all of
that [ __ ] yeah okay everybody should
have a [ __ ] at-bat right so they're
sitting there bitching that's like a big
[ __ ] thing right now but guys make
more in sports and blah blah blah blah
and they have like they're catering to
men alright and just a completely
ignoring CTE and all of the [ __ ]
damage that happens to these guys and
how the owners don't give a [ __ ] and
you're just a completely it's a [ __ ]
piece of meat right you know the reason
why they're paying you that money is
because you're they're making way more
money off of you this [ __ ] [ __ ]
like women should be like the WNBA those
games should be [ __ ] Pat yeah with
women with their face painted swinging
their bras over they had acting like
[ __ ] lunatics if they did that the
industry would be like they would be
like wait a minute yeah this is like the
[ __ ] thing but they don't yeah where
are they
they're watching the [ __ ] Kardashians
and look at her yeah she [ __ ] goes eh
I tried out this eye cream today she
gets six figures for tweeting yeah cuz
that's where they are
yeah and they're [ __ ] sitting there
wasting their [ __ ] time we're gonna
sue this and blah blah blah blah blah
the biggest [ __ ] thing they should be
supporting each other rather than trying
to become a ref in the NFL who gives a
[ __ ] you still working for guys cuz
right now like as far as like a guy if
you wanted to start your own sports
league it's [ __ ] over you can't do it
it's too established but with women to
do like an AFL type thing or an ABA
thing is [ __ ] wide open yeah yeah so
what they should do just get their money
together start their own [ __ ] women's
hockey league and women should go out
and [ __ ] support it and then it'll
become this thing and then the NHL
eventually would be like hey man we want
to buy in oh yeah and then you make your
money on all the power yeah yeah
you [ __ ] sit there and like there
would be like uh you know back in the
day when no one wanted me like you know
there's a lot of balding redheaded males
out there who actually act like how far
would I get how much longer we're suit
we're gonna sue the Improv sue The
Improv because
redheads because you're not you're not
gonna [ __ ] book me as a headliner
before I'm gonna draw yeah oh yeah so
that's the thing about the those those
sports and [ __ ] it's just like once as
much as they are they are getting [ __ ]
and all that stuff but it's just like
that's not the way to go about it like
the WNBA game should be packed with
women yeah [ __ ] packed and they
should be going [ __ ] nuts and by in
March and having jerseys the same way
meathead guys like me yeah do it
yeah yeah yeah that's the only reason
why they need to get some rivalries
going they need to legit hate another
[ __ ] female team so it becomes
Celtics Lakers pistons-bulls whatever
the [ __ ] you want it you got it you got
to have it I don't know man yeah maybe
that's it there's no rivalry between the
the teams because you do have to have
that you have to have that full rivalry
right like that's my team dude I was
reading this whole thing unlike the NBA
right yeah and what they had to do to
sell the game like Bill Russell and
those guys back in the day when there
was like eight teams they might I just
had Don Gavin on my podcast he used to
go and watch Bill Russell read our back
coach and all issue and to play for a
championship and a half-filled Boston
Garden oh yeah
so because no one knew about the league
nobody gave a [ __ ] so what these guys
would do during the offseason is they
would play basically like some soccer a
friendly where it didn't mean anything
they would go fly down to the south just
try and sell the product well crazy pro
basketball basketball yeah basketball
like you know the same way the NFL like
college basketball was way bigger than
the NFL all of them had to sell it and
because of what they did the kids now
come along and they're making in like as
a man you can make all this if you're
good enough can make all this money in
all these leagues because of the
sacrifices these other guys made so the
women now have to do that yeah get out
there and just sell the [ __ ] game and
then they got to put out a product
that's gonna make women go down there
and watch that [ __ ] instead of the
[ __ ] Real Housewives and the
Kardashians yeah you gotta fill if you
got a fill of
and you yeah Kings of Comedy did it
you know the [ __ ] though the redneck
tour what the [ __ ] are called blue
collars are calm collar comedy they
[ __ ] did it
that's what I'm trying to do right now
I'm gonna try to build my own thing no
one's touching me so I'm like [ __ ] it I
got to build my own thing you know it's
it's I just keep doing it and doing the
thing about it when you in that mindset
yeah
okay then you have power yeah because
then you you still have control of it if
you're gonna just sit there with oh you
can't do this because of this you can't
do that because of that and then these
[ __ ] people blah blah blah blah it's
just like yeah all of that's going on
what are you gonna do about it yeah
nothing you can [ __ ] do about it you
just [ __ ] put your head down and sell
what the [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you're doing it
said man I gotta tell you though those
[ __ ] people though who are the guy
that they're looking for the
good-looking people and all that they
this shelf life they if they're like
[ __ ] organic food you don't expire
yeah by the time you get home it's
already starting to go bad like this
[ __ ] strawberries they'll start
shriveling up so anyway so I find the
whole thing like like interesting and I
was sitting there going like why these
athletes this [ __ ] good and I don't
know who they are
Yeah right part of its because I have a
kid and all that other another [ __ ] but
like a lot of it is like you know as
much as wokai ESPN oh they're sexist
saying they'll mainly show guys sports
well that's where the money's at yeah
that's all they care about money is that
I don't care about anything they don't
get do you think they give a [ __ ] that
the NBA is sold this their soul to the
super team yeah
no no if I see one more [ __ ] [ __ ]
in the NBA go we always still a couple
pieces away it's like it's all started
with the dream team in the Olympics you
know they put that together they mowed
over everybody and then the NBA was like
hey man if we do a dream team people are
gonna follow that team for my theories
is because the league almost bankrupted
yeah in the lates what happened in the
70s was
the ABA came and took half their stars
and then the league also went from being
predominantly white to predominantly
black and there was all these older
white people like I don't want to watch
that dr. J why would you want to watch
that best I don't know yeah a man the
soul and then cocaine came out yeah and
then there was a bunch of players on
that stuff and it was just a bad like
they were in this transition where it
went from like 80% white guys to like
80% black guys and then cocaine was
involved as far as like cocaine first
came out they were saying that it was no
more addictive than caffeine oh yeah it
was a Letus [ __ ] drug and it took all
of these people down so the league was
they had drug problems they had did
[ __ ] old racist people [ __ ] not
liking the [ __ ] so they were in a bad
way and then it just so happened luck of
the draw bird goes to Boston magic goes
to the Lakers and then you had the 80s
yeah yeah if you got you got cream I'll
deal Jabbar yeah I got these cool
marquee players I mean I was so into AB
but the Lakers were those were all
[ __ ] draft picks other than Kareem
right right we were all in and then also
shrewd trades yeah and that's what the
Lakers are doing that's what the Celtics
did and then we just old-school way
there was these two super teams and then
the ratings were through the [ __ ]
roof and then as they started to fade
Jordan go Pistons and then Jordan came
along and they had like this 15-year I
feel like 20-year windfall and they were
like that became like their product and
they just wanted it to keep going
so then I think then that's when you got
the Kobe Shaq Phil Jackson Laker then
you got the LeBron [ __ ] the other
Boston big three yeah they're from last
we've heard last place to winning the
championship in a year was ridiculous
had the big three then the heat yeah
then Golden State yeah and now look at
the Lakers you know with their big three
it's just kind of like I don't know yeah
a lot of things happen to sneaker
culture but I'm saying ESPN yeah should
be going the [ __ ] happened to this
league yeah
you know when Jordan lost to the Pistons
he didn't join the Pistons yeah he
[ __ ] lifted weights and [ __ ] yeah
you know Betar gonna get him we're gonna
get it became a challenge yeah I don't I
don't they don't give a [ __ ] they give a
[ __ ] about money so going back to that
female like athletic athletics and all
that type of [ __ ]
there's absolutely sexism this
absolutely [ __ ] that isn't fair but at
the end of the [ __ ] day the golden
ticket is money yeah in ticket sales and
you have to go out there and [ __ ] put
your head down and do what all these
other [ __ ] men's leagues did back in
the day when they almost fold they all
almost folded yeah the [ __ ] during
the Depression the NHL lost half of
their [ __ ] teams that's why he had
the original six they were really the
surviving six right yeah sells cars
about the fold man yeah NASCAR's going
through some [ __ ] that's going through
some [ __ ] man yeah and that was from the
[ __ ] bankers is what [ __ ] them over
because they had you know working-class
people would come out and then the the
[ __ ] a couple things happen they they
kind of had a little drought and stars
it happens yeah yeah they did do that
yeah so they had a little drought in
that and then also 2008 banking scandal
left so many people upside down in their
[ __ ] houses yeah
Fannie Mae all that stuff oh and then
the piece of [ __ ] moves at those [ __ ]
banks did to force people the worst
thing ever I told you you know my
[ __ ] house right when the roof yeah
collapsed what the water came in and all
of that [ __ ] when I got my insurance
money it was made out to me and the bank
that owned my mortgage and I had to sign
the money over to them that's like wait
this is my money yeah yeah my roof yeah
and it's my [ __ ] money well this is
what they did they [ __ ] so many people
over so bad on their houses that when
when people were getting insurance
claims like their house was never gonna
be worth more than what they owed so
they said [ __ ] they went out bought a
car had a cake party or whatever yeah
and then what happens they default in
the [ __ ] loan and then the bank would
get it back and they had to fix the
house right the wrath of walk on it so
if they did then was they came up with
this [ __ ] thing they just pushed
through politicians always push it
through cuz they're grossly underpaid
set up to be bribed by insurance
companies pharmaceutical companies and
all that [ __ ] they
push the [ __ ] thing through then your
insurance company went to them and then
and then they were doing inspections to
make sure the work was actually [ __ ]
being done so they would slowly release
the [ __ ] money I was so [ __ ] pet
as I said they go like my checkbook is
balanced [ __ ] you to sit there
yeah he's think I had a guy write in and
was saying like I hate when you say that
politicians are [ __ ] underpaid and he
goes this is the average salary you know
of a politician this is the average
salary as the average working person
it's like well the average working
person isn't running a town yeah running
the country yeah yeah you should make
more money
yeah the average [ __ ] guy bagging
groceries at a [ __ ] Trader Joe's yeah
and the amount of [ __ ] they got to go
through to get there oh that's not
especially now where they just dig into
your past and everything
your whole family's out there I know
here's the thing - I actually think you
know if you gave politicians [ __ ] you
money then it would it would still just
attract bad people that's why I just
love people that have a problem with
[ __ ] Bernie Sanders the the [ __ ]
[ __ ] that that guy says he said the
other day he was talking about [ __ ]
health care yeah and he was I'm gonna
butcher it he said something like like
every single day like whatever like
every year all of these Americans lose
their jobs and go bankrupt and what is
their crime he goes they got cancer huh
and he goes and unless this party is
gonna and he goes that they they like
500,000 people lost all of this money
because they got cancer and that jobs
and all this type of stuff and then was
saying that the healthcare industry made
12 billion dollars last year he goes
unless we as a party are gonna stand up
to that you know then basically what the
[ __ ] are we he had like the [ __ ]
balls to say that I'm just trying to
wrap my head around somebody listening
to that who's fighting for [ __ ]
people with with cancer and then you're
looking at a guy who just hugged and
kissed a flag and said I love you in
that latest one yeah yeah all's I care
about is anyone that talks about
healthcare cuz they in the last couple
years I've had like health problems and
I'm like I got
listen to this guy you know I just want
somebody who actually has the balls to
stand up to pharmaceutical companies to
[ __ ] insurance companies yeah cuz
they [ __ ] everybody over and here's
the thing dude you know what's what's
[ __ ] up about me politically is I grew
up in a conservative house I still have
a lot of that in me yeah I'm definitely
liberal but I have a lot of that and I
like a lot of Republican candidates yeah
it's Chris Rock thing never I'm half
Republican and half Democrat
yeah aren't you definitely lean to his
side but if I leave his side I
definitely mean liberal right but I just
my [ __ ] thing is I just don't want
another [ __ ] company man yeah okay
and I think that that's what happened
the last the last time out was you had
one guy who was not a company man and
then you had Hillary who was a company
man and which was just they were
offering more the same versus somebody
who was yeah he was responding to the
anger that was out there I just do you
know and just it's for an entertainment
value I just want to see a Trump Bernie
Sanders debate yeah this country is
really just gonna go down the [ __ ]
yeah I that's the one I want to see that
it's gonna be great and then and then
some great spoofs on it too on SNL when
they're just spoofing it the whole time
I know I don't know it's it's a [ __ ]
it's a crazy thing it's a crazy thing so
whatever I just hope somebody competent
I don't give a [ __ ] Democrat a
Republican yeah there's somebody
competent that gives a [ __ ] about people
well you're Larry and that type of [ __ ]
and like like dude how [ __ ] up is it
that we have to drink bottled water you
even think about that
they allowed these corporations to just
completely pollute our [ __ ] waters
that's something Isis wants to do yeah
yeah you know yeah let people just
[ __ ] create a [ __ ] drug epidemic
yeah not telling people how addictive
this [ __ ] is that's fine the [ __ ]
bankers [ __ ] everybody over and then you
know I have a hole in my roof and then
they take my insurance money and make
sure I put it's just like
yeah nobody on either side that's why I
don't watch CNN or Fox you know it's
[ __ ] hilarious is I get a buddy of
mine you know that coronavirus and shift
this scaring the [ __ ] out of people yeah
yeah you know like that like that's
gonna that that's what's gonna take us
out right so yeah you know but he kind
of bought into it a little bit so he
bought some groceries and [ __ ] so he
called up his folks home back home and
all they do is watch Fox News
oh no so he called him up and the his
dad just went off saying it was all a
[ __ ] hoax started by the Democrats to
try to take out Trump and it's just like
hilarious it's just like saying - I was
going through that's why you can't watch
those channels no because I which I
would love is if he called up someone
who all he do is watch CNN like what are
they saying though yeah you know yeah
just his [ __ ] bet he's [ __ ] crazy
they're [ __ ] crazy dude it's insane
like I was at the airport yesterday
people are people are going crazy
actually
actually crazy people at the airport I'm
kind of loving it though because yeah
there's people overreacting so like
there's nobody on the roads that anybody
flies I saw this great parking house it
The Improv a couple nights ago yeah guys
coronavirus great look at the parking
yeah it's awesome
parking is great and I love when I see
people who [ __ ] going nuts with the
mass and [ __ ] yeah yeah I love it cuz
well I know they got it yeah that's
great yeah quarantine yourself I love it
I love people doing all of that [ __ ] I
was supposed to go to South by Southwest
to do the premiere of king of Staten
Island Judd Apatow Pete Davidson movie
and that just got canceled so that would
have been fun to get together with the
cast so hopefully we're gonna be able to
get to do that but you'll have to do it
in a bubble like that old Tron Travolta
film boy in the plastic bubble well it
all seems if you keep you know you take
in vitamin C and you keep yourself yeah
like healthy you know and it that you
can either ride it out or you're not
going to get it yeah I said more people
died from the flu ass
and no one talks about that you know
well cuz the flu you can get a flu shot
and everything I mean look it they're
doing the right thing
no yeah now but I mean with with like
news agencies like news channels like
[ __ ] scaring the [ __ ] out of people
and then then then they once they've
done that then they come back I like our
people overreacting it's just like oh
you mean from the information that
you've been [ __ ] spewing out yeah
here you give us all day long we've got
another one here I know anyway actually
I gotta I gotta read I got to read some
some advertising here alright really
quickly then we'll get back to this yeah
dude I can't have [ __ ] wait I've been
practicing the drums and all that [ __ ]
oh I've been practicing man that's
[ __ ] tricky song man yeah which ones
are you playing I'm playing the jack and
then problem child oh yeah yeah you know
somebody before you read the ad I was at
Austin last night and this guy said to
me he goes he was a fan of the
podcasting because you excited for
Tuesday I mean like this is your thing
right and I go I said hey man you know
it [ __ ] excites me I I did this you
know for me it's Bill and Marin because
those guys the excitement they get is
the excitement I get when I open for you
guys you know it's the excitement I have
is after it's over yeah [ __ ] it up too
bad I'm saying that's my thing of like
it's the only thing I can really get
back to you guys as far as like from
opening for you guys and learning from
you so it's the equivalent they did
Marin by that guitar by the way yeah
yeah the sound is so good on I said you
dean posted this thing of marin just
trying out this guitar yeah I can really
play mad yeah he plays ever he loves it
yeah he can really he looks playing like
I love comedy now you know so he keeps
talking about planning my cool man hey
that one joke you know it's so funny oh
he's in a big movie coming up yeah yes
what is he in I saw a clip he's in a
Mark Wahlberg one that came out Friday
it's on Netflix right now okay yeah and
then his specials out tomorrow on
Netflix thank you I'm gonna watch that
Manuel Berg always makes good movies
yeah all right Oh max Oh max Oh max
living with chronic pain is the worst
many of my listeners probably have some
type of pain that has prevented them
from relaxing and sleeping or stop them
from exercising perhaps it's been
ongoing for a few weeks now and hasn't
improved with any of the treatments
they've tried Oh max health I say
podcasts host to provide experience of
recent pain ow my [ __ ] shoulder my
left shoulder after Oh max health if
you're looking to get a rid of a nagging
muscle and joint pain immediately while
providing long lasting recovery then you
need to try the natural breakthrough
pain relief solution cryofreeze CBD
roll-on developed by Oh max health I
should use that on my [ __ ] hand I bet
that's work cuz I member you use it on
yours when you you were from all those
years you work in the clutch there on
your motorcycle this is a
non-prescription triple action pain
relief roll-on specially formulated to
block pain receptors reduce inflammation
and improve muscle and joint flexibility
so it doesn't just numb it the best part
is this 100% natural CBD powered remedy
works its magic within 10 minutes of
application and release relief lasts up
to 8 hours much longer than
over-the-counter products Oh max Health
is offering my listeners 20% off a full
bottle of cryo free CBD pain relief
roll-on plus free shipping this discount
also applies towards any product
site-wide just go - Oh max health om ax
health.com today and enter the promo
code birbee URR that's oma X health calm
and enter the code bird to get 20% off
cryofreeze and site-wide is this it no
it just keeps going like that felt like
the end anyone from athletes to grandma
Josie can benefit from this immediate
pain relief you have we know we know it
[ __ ] works cryo free works within 10
min
it's of application improving physical
training recovering and performance to
go - Oh max health calm enter the promo
code bird to get 20% off cryofreeze
and site-wide alright helix HELOCs
this is the last one here alright is my
helix add I'm hi I'm Bill burr oh this
is I like when they try to get into my
voice here hi I'm Bill burr I'm a really
unique guy that's why you like my
podcast or don't like it I don't care
this is like who do you think I am I
don't care I care I care what people
think about me I wouldn't be in this
business look at me I'm on stage do you
approve anyways but I'm truly one of a
kind evidently which is why I sleep on a
mattress designed specifically for me
and you can't - next please mention all
the talking points below I've told these
people a zillion times if they write it
I'm gonna read it
alright HELOCs sleep helix built a sleep
quiz that takes two minutes to complete
and they use the answers to match your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you if you like a
mattress that's really soft or firm you
sleep on your side of your back or your
stomach or you sleep really hot gross
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and everybody's unique tastes
like me what about Bill Brewer is like
our product that's what they did with
this thing just go to helix sleep calm
slash bro take their two minutes sleep
quiz and they'll match you to the
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life like me I guess I'll
like put people to sleep helix sleep was
a war even a warning the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2019 by GQ &
Wired magazine they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for a
hundred nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up if you don't like it that's
pretty nice and gross right now hellix
is offering up to $200 off mattress
orders for our listeners get up to $200
off helix helix sleep comm / / atli x
sleep comm / / get the best mattress you
could ever [ __ ] sleep on all right
there we go
oh congratulations to Joe Roberts the
first American in MotoGP to be on the
all sent in like 10 years Wow MotoGP too
so he's one level below he wrote a great
race you know and I didn't have the best
start it was immediately in third place
but then worked his way up to second for
brief second did lead the race but this
this Japanese kid hope I say this right
Tetsu te' Nagashima thought he was like
an eighth place just worked his way up
through the pack he's consistently
having the fastest lap so when he
finally got out front nobody could catch
him and it was the first time I believe
a Japanese rider has has stood won a
race since in ten years and that last
guy I think he I think he died I'm new
to the sport but I believe he died later
on that year so it was a very emotional
thing it's a great race to see I don't
know what happened with the MotoGP race
I wasn't able to find it I slept through
it but I go to the website so I don't
know who won that one
Mack Mack has or whatever is my guess
all right so Dean I got it we got some
questions here you want to run through
these [ __ ] things yeah well write in
another [ __ ] I kind of got involved with
the flat earth people know what what's
your feeling what's your feeling man is
it rounder is it flat oh my god [ __ ] man
it's a flat earthers did they think the
moon's also flat or do they think that
that's around other they think they're
looking at like a cookie I think they're
looking at a platter up there yeah yeah
yeah it's dual platters so then like I
don't know man I just I it's so weird
how something like that just comes out
of nowhere that's like a couple years
old now came out of nowhere they're like
the earth is flat I thought it was like
a sketch or something yeah I'm looking
forward and then I just start laughing I
like when I think is what the end game
yeah I understand
you know conspiracies on like you know
bankers yeah assassination of powerful
people or people like they think are
gonna be powerful I get all of that what
the [ __ ] what is the end
and then the amount of [ __ ] people
yeah they finally get my bed you would
have to get on board oh it's crazy right
and and also why do they think that we
would be hiding that from them you know
about every [ __ ] jerk-off who sails
their dreams to sail around the world
and then they go do it yeah I know you
know guy flew up in Vancouver flew a
[ __ ] helicopter around the world now
what do they do to stop him from doing
that doesn't he fly off the [ __ ] edge
and come back and have a look on his
face I mean I don't know
anyways motive for telling people the
earth is round all right here we go like
you can't believe like this his people
this is like a real [ __ ] thing listen
to this [ __ ] all right this is the
motive why you would tell people hey hey
hey Billy blue button-up wanted to tell
you my opinion on what the motive of
telling people the earth is round is I
like you understand that the only reason
we know the earth is round is because we
were told that I was joking about that
like the only reason I know it's round
is because somebody told me yeah yeah I
didn't figure it out most people just
call me a [ __ ] idiot like they're
Nikolai Tesla or something the motive
for this of course is money the first
movie made about space was a trip to the
moon it was made in 1902 by a dude named
George's don't worry neither of us can
pronounce his last name after that movie
killed way back in the day they started
making space movies left and right space
and the thought of going to space has
been in the back of our minds for over a
hundred years it spawned countless cash
cows like Star Wars Star Trek and even
MTV's most iconic marketing gimmick was
the astronaut pitting the MTV flag on
the moon I don't know where he's going
with this so it'd be very easy to get
those people on board with being the
first country to fly to the moon getting
all these people wrapped up in the idea
of space would be a good way of getting
them to agree to pour their tax money
into your space program and if you think
about it billions
he'll probably help probably trillions
of American tax dollars have gone
to NASA and all they would have to do is
get us to give them our money is to show
us some pictures of the moon from close
up in the earth from far away and then
from about the sixties on I don't know
what we go with this we poured our money
into the space program money would be
the motive bill I believe in Flat Earth
but I also don't know the earth is flat
and I'm not going to tell you it is but
this is my opinion I also used to try to
tell everybody that the earth is flat
and argue at them for hours but we both
know that the shape of the earth is not
important what's important is saving it
and making it a healthy place for our
kid regardless if it's flat round or
doughnut shape take care bill oh and
let's go blues blues blues looking good
yeah hurry so he wanted to get tax
dollars so they showed a photo of around
Earth yeah but what they don't talk
about is how way back in the day we
thought it was flat yeah and then this
guy comes out he says no it's round and
then they kill him yeah and then we also
thought we were the center of the
[ __ ] universe or the solar system
then they realized it was the Sun they
thought the Sun went around us we were
rowing around the [ __ ] Sun you know
all of this [ __ ] has been like proven I
know because of the American space
program the entire world's leaders have
agreed to lie in scientists that the
[ __ ] thing is round yeah all of them
this is one of the this is one of the
worst conspira-con Spira see there's no
I this is one of the worst ones ever
yeah it's like going back we're going
back in time I think it's just people
like to be right it's like there's a
certain level of contrarian here yeah
and then wanting to be right well that's
the whole what's going on you're like
sure thing is why doesn't a flat earther
just go to the [ __ ] edge of the earth
and take a picture like there are Nagre
fault yeah yeah a selfie on the edge how
doesn't the water from the ocean pour Oh
this side somebody was joking said it's
like they think it's a giant infinity
pool alright Flat Earth answers dude and
I will go with any [ __ ] conspiracy
theory or not any but like Jesus dude
this is like this isn't he this is not
even cent rooted in anything other than
just being a contrarian okay hey Bill
you asked about the Flat Earth and why
they would lie about it that's a good
question that everyone who looks into it
into this ass the answer is money the
taxpayers have given Ness its oh we got
another one saying yeah but my thing is
evidently like 500 [ __ ] years ago
they knew NASA was coming so that's why
they started saying it was round well he
said they made the movie in 1902
billions or even trillions of dollars
over the years to get some shitty ass
space videos in return and it gets
deeper than that I didn't know we were
deep there's a video you should watch
called the history of Flat Earth I will
definitely watch this if the link
doesn't work go to Eric Dubay channel
and in the search bar search the history
of Flat Earth it's easy to prove the
earth is flat in stationary like how the
North Star never moves well what about
the rest of the stars that's why it's
the North Star cuz it's not [ __ ]
that's the one you're looking at yeah
they're all spinning around that so
that's what you use to guide yourself
that's your pinpoint yeah
what the [ __ ] so if you [ __ ] put it
if you color if you were looking down on
a merry-go-round yeah and you just
painted the Middle's red and the rest of
it was all these crazy colors you would
ignore all those other colors moving and
just look at that red dot going see it's
not moving yeah that's hilarious anyways
if this link doesn't work go to Eric
turbo well this is just a bunch of
people who are not eggheads
trying to figure it out egghead [ __ ]
alright I don't understand half of this
[ __ ] I would love to listen to Joe Rogan
argue this the history of Flat Earth it
is easy to prove the earth is flying the
North Star never moves or we can see way
further then should be possible on a
globe
oh my god I had many others can we see
how far are you supposed to see on a
globe I bet you didn't know that to this
day there's never been a successful
experiment to prove the earth has
curvature or is moving I I did not know
that I thought there was plenty of
evidence please please watch this video
I know you're a busy guy but it will
explain the subject to you correctly and
without the [ __ ] alright well I got
to watch it then yeah it's called the
history of Flat Earth what's that on
YouTube yeah they've been lying about
the earth being round for hundreds of
years because they knew NASA was coming
yeah NASA people lied about it who were
gonna die hundreds of years before NASA
came along it's all various man listen
if you want to say we never went to the
moon and [ __ ] like that like cuz I don't
get how you land and then you get the
[ __ ] thing going again how do you
start it back up that's a classic one
you know they they said that a Stanley
Kubrick shot the film he shot the
footage oh yeah yeah no on a Hollywood
backlot I don't know I don't understand
why doesn't NASA just take a picture of
the [ __ ] car and [ __ ] they left
behind them yeah what do they just do
that there this is right [ __ ] there
where we left it there's a shift 50
[ __ ] years ago I have no [ __ ] idea
all right Paris Accords Paris Accords is
like a Honda Accord all right I want to
talk a little bit about how terrible the
Paris agreement really was with the idea
in mind that maybe there is some
controversy to the effects in cause of
global warming
for starters over a 20-year period the
Paris Accord was estimated to cost the
United States some 2.5 trillion dollars
in what doing the right thing the
entirety of the US yearly budget is
three point eight trillion dollars so
essentially we would lose 10% of our net
budget every year for this agreement so
what so we could have a clean earth that
our children and our children's children
could live on you're gonna skimp on this
but your are you okay with never-ending
Wars that don't really have an exit
strategy that money has to come from
somewhere so either taxes are going up
or social spending is getting cut
because the military definitely isn't
paying for it I love how people are
putting money ahead of [ __ ] being
able to live here oh yeah that was my
mom who gives a fine earth you know like
like that opening the drilling in
national parks and stuff like what are
you what are you talking about you know
I just coal bringing coal back you know
all right and I'm not saying that the
Paris Accord wasn't flawed all right but
you also have a guy who's who is in
power saying that the whole thing is a
hoax which is [ __ ] scary all right so
we're really gonna read all of this [ __ ]
cuz the guy's he's not he listens listen
for this sentence second the Paris
Accord was set up to collect over 100
billion dollars per year into green
energy funds to promote green energy
this is a [ __ ] term that I despise
but I won't get into it all right well
then okay so then what are you see
you're just gonna kind of skim over your
argument it sounds wonderful in Princes
principle but in fact the people in
charge of the Commission will have final
say over where that money ends up I'd
bet both my testicles if this thing
continues into the future the people
getting the money will just happen to be
the people related to or direct
responsible for the politicians that
proposed it why not just cut out the
middleman and fork over the 10% of my
paycheck to politicians and questions
seems like a lot of Hoops to jump
through for what will obviously end in
corruption well everything's going to
end in corruption at least they're
trying to do something
third the acordes is set to cut the
emission of Western nations by about 20
percent
considering that these countries only
account for 21 percent with the United
States producing 14 percent itself of
the total world greenhouse gas admission
that means that they would have a net
effect of cutting global emissions by
roughly four percent considering I don't
know this is like
I don't know III okay all right - you're
right we shouldn't do anything we
shouldn't do any we should we should
pull out of these [ __ ] things it's
like no one's gonna we're literally
gonna sit there and argue with each
other and that's that's how we're going
out yeah that's how we are going out it
is that's how we're going I don't
understand why we don't just embrace
solar power I don't get it either okay I
don't even give a [ __ ] if it's dirtier
just to get us out of that [ __ ] in
the Middle East to get us off of oil as
much as humanly possible because at the
end of the day you're still gonna have
to have gears and [ __ ] turning in metal
against metal you're gonna need you need
a lubricant you're gonna need that
alright in the same way with the [ __ ]
solar panels I'm sure there's some sort
of [ __ ] generator that it goes into
that also [ __ ] needs well but not as
much right so my thing is the Middle
East is like I remember those his
[ __ ] always used this example it was
a store in the South Shore Plaza when I
was a kid it was called wicks and sticks
all they sold was candles yeah wigs and
still that's all they [ __ ] sold so
basically it was just one of those
things where if for some [ __ ] reason
no one one day somebody decides like you
know I'd [ __ ] candles or some [ __ ]
comes out with candles that there's a
carcinogen yeah or somebody burns down
their [ __ ] house it's a terrible
story they're going out of business
they're [ __ ] I look at the Middle East
like that that's wicks and sticks they
sell oil that's it that's their baby
that finances [ __ ] everything it
finances the terrorist groups that are
coming at all of us and if we just
[ __ ] embrace the different kind of
[ __ ] energy walked away from that
[ __ ] as much as we did over there yeah
as much as we did over there they would
forget about us within two [ __ ] years
and would be right back to [ __ ] going
after each other the same way when
Russia [ __ ] pulled out of Eastern
Europe how long before that whole
Bosnian Serb think we even knew that
they didn't [ __ ] like each other I
didn't the whole time they were under
they had a common enemy Russia when I
was a kid and then all of a sudden they
pulled out and then all that horrific
[ __ ] happened not saying I want that to
happen in the Middle East but I'm just
saying yeah get out of there yeah get
the [ __ ] out of it I don't even get the
solar-powered thing like you know they
got it out in Vegas now like
you know they got that giant solar farm
out there and then all our downtown is
run on solar now that's great I know
it's awesome they have so much power
they don't know what to do with it this
is free gallons of power you know it's
not amazing it's free we're still over
there [ __ ] with this dirty goop it's
creating what it kills me - all these
[ __ ] years of people [ __ ] on an
electric car that it came to go up a
hill
it's the fastest [ __ ] things out
there oh yeah it's a stupid Tesla
looking car I drop that dumbass looking
[ __ ] at it I don't know what the [ __ ]
that thing looks like it's like cotton
Dockers of cars yeah yeah I think
[ __ ] rocks man that thing will
[ __ ] that thinks faster than a
Ferrari Yeah right new in the new
Porsche oh the electric one crazy god
200 miles an hour what the [ __ ] are we
doing the problem is is you just have
like the old boys network they're not
gonna let go of this their way yeah well
I know what you gotta do is you gotta
give the solar power to the oil
companies yeah well I gotta give it to
them that's right we still feel like
they're running [ __ ] and just get the
[ __ ] out of there yeah leave the tobacco
industry they they slept on the weed
industry and now they're like well
tobacco's going to be over with one day
so they're funding to ban weed so they
can get caught up and then once it's
this band then they go now we'll own it
and then they can be in the weed
business oh they're fighting to ban it
yeah like secretly funding to ban weed
all the time it's you know isn't that so
that people will keep smoking their
[ __ ] no it's so they can catch up
because they know of cigarettes events
we are gonna be out of here there's no
way you know what I'm saying
and then guards will never be gone so no
cigars but I [ __ ] quit cigars yeah
yeah sucks I smoked one Tuesday when I
went to a Laker game with virzi here so
I've had like one in like 50 yeah but
this weekend you know I went away I had
a little staycation with my lovely wife
we had a [ __ ] great time
it was [ __ ] man I went back to this
hotel that we stayed at before
or were the last time I went there with
her I got [ __ ] plastered whoa every
time yeah and I was smoking cigars like
I was you know yeah [ __ ] idiot so I
went back there and it was all of those
I actually went into the bar and I was
looking to see if they still had that
bottle of Kentucky owl then I was [ __ ]
hittin every night and the guy goes
gonna get your drink I said nah man I'm
sober I go I'm just [ __ ] what did I say
I said something I'm just um I'm just
reminiscing or so I don't know we're
gonna know ghosts yeah I was just
checking him out or whatever and but you
know but I went the whole weekend and I
was really fighting you know that
smoking another cigar but that was just
going like all right just think it
through what are you doing here why are
you doing this you're just getting
triggered because this is what you did
here the last time you just need to
create new memories here of not doing
this [ __ ] and you'll be fine I remember
I will and then I woke up this morning
and I was driving back to the house and
I didn't do any of that [ __ ] and I was
psyched and now I could give a [ __ ]
about having a cigar so it's just like
I'm not gonna fully give up cigars as
far as like but like I would like to
smoke like for a year it's something
epic just the Rose Bowl yeah Rose Bowl I
go to a big college game with my buddies
maybe my birthday or something like that
or if a buddy's in town like first he
was in town I really want to smoke a
[ __ ] cigar I haven't drank and since
2018 whoa
2018 yeah the end of 2018 so I was like
I got to [ __ ] do something here you
know yeah so and I just picked the
smallest one that they had and I smoked
then I got down to towards the end I
just [ __ ] put it out and I don't know
what kind of getting off the topic here
but I I I think that okay in defense of
the guy who wrote in I don't know [ __ ]
about the Paris agreement yeah okay so
and I'm sure that there's a whole bunch
of information on why we should and a
whole bunch of information of why we
shouldn't
maybe we shouldn't be in it I don't know
let's just say that's it but I I can't
deal with someone who just thinks the
whole [ __ ] thing is a hoax let's just
even say that like global warming isn't
caused by us just in general what the
[ __ ] we're doing to the ocean we
shouldn't be doing oh it would be nicer
to just live in a cleaner [ __ ] world
you know my daughter has these books
right you know that make way for
ducklings Robert McCloskey or something
and what's great is the illustrations
and you just see like there's one book
call it's called one morning in Maine
and you just see when they get up be
they drew like the kitchen and [ __ ] and
everything's just made out of wood it's
made out of steel and all of this and
it's all like no plastic yeah and it's
just as far as like you know the dad's
down on the beach he's digging for clams
okay the girl gets like a loose tooth
you know she's learning you know she's
becoming a bigger girl it's kinda what
the books about right she goes down
there and [ __ ] they get the clams he
packs him in seaweed to keep a moist
they go up there and then they're gonna
go into town cuz he's got to get the
groceries and he's returning the glass
milk bottles right she goes I'll have
clam chowder ready for you when you get
back
they [ __ ] going into the stupid
outboard motor doesn't start they go in
town there's a repair guy there needs a
new spark plug he fixes that they get
[ __ ] ice cream and and there's all
this wildlife there's all this [ __ ]
going on and I was kind of looking at
that
mccrane you could also get [ __ ] polio
back then so pay for yeah but I was just
kind of looking at that like how simple
their life was and I know it's just a
book but like that whole thing were
somehow along the line where you you
stop getting [ __ ] repaired and it was
cheaper to throw it out yeah and get
something new ocean is yeah dude that is
that was a that was not a good idea yeah
in the short run it was a good idea yeah
financially it was a good idea like
these stupid [ __ ] chargers man
for these things like the fact that they
can't make one to just work yeah I know
you know and all it's just gonna be like
they designed like that what are they
called design obsolescence or something
like now No
yeah the lineup designed obsolescence is
basically you design the thing to last
long enough where the person's not going
to be mad and they'll still have till go
out and go buy another one rather than
just making the [ __ ] thing right
instead of feeling ripped off and went
just amount of time but that's like the
sneakers man like sneakers are just you
know people buy millions of sneakers
every day and then they just fall apart
and then they just toss them you know
I'm like I get those boots from the kid
and they like the last a hundred years
you know I'm saying that everything back
then you just you weren't and then your
next family war and then the next family
war yeah now it was wild it was just it
was in cars you just drove the car
really just looking around my house all
this [ __ ] that I've bought yeah and all
this stuff that I have and all of this
[ __ ] and I'm just like why did I do this
yeah like I'm gonna die someday and
somebody's gonna have to deal with all
of this [ __ ] well that's why I've been
getting rid all my [ __ ] I've been trying
but you can't throw it out though no I
don't throw it out you gotta give it to
people yeah just sell it but I'm just
selling a couple of things for me right
yeah yeah I getting rid of everything
all of it you know
because it's like I had that fear when I
thought I had a stroke
all's I kept thinking was all that [ __ ]
in my place people are gonna have to
deal with it I swear I had you so when
your life was flashing before you that's
what you were thinking of I was just
saying I was you know I was thinking
dude I was thinking a lot of blue sins
right now a lot of loose ends you know I
got it I got I gotta get all my [ __ ]
together and then if some was money my
wife is upset with me as far as my death
package that I put together yeah so I
have my fares in order and I'm like I'm
gonna be an organ donor yeah yeah and
then we have to you know course take the
parts out yeah cuz I could literally
save like once you have like a kid or
something like the
what do you that yeah it's like
somebody's kid you could like you know
everybody out here was somebody's kid
and they love him to death and if I'm
done using my [ __ ] chick and I take
that [ __ ] yeah yeah and then they just
gonna [ __ ] burn me up and then that's
gonna be it telling me she's like no ya
know as he goes no you have to be
[ __ ] buried next to me and I would
just laughed I go I go there's really no
way out of this relationship is there'll
be right next to me right there oh man
but she you know yeah it means it in
like a romantic like my thing is like
you know if we're not gonna do anything
about the population problem I'm not
taking up a patch of [ __ ] grass for
the rest of time when I'm out of here
yeah yeah same here I'm out of here I'm
gonna show yourselves I'm not in the
nightmare one where I want my friends to
throw my ashes off Half Dome cuz I'm
from you sanity I got you gotta go
hiking you know they get halfway there
in the bank hey he's not around this
just tosses and go down to the bar down
in the awani hotel yeah like I think
they should just like I don't know I'm a
big believer in getting the [ __ ] out of
the way when she had your thing get the
[ __ ] out of the way you're a young
person go out to clubs have a good time
then you become older ya can't stay out
of the [ __ ] clubs that's for young
people that's it's their time don't be
that creepy guy oh yeah I was on sick
Street last night it was so loud you
know Austin every bar and I was like I'm
just walking to my hotel like is there a
side street you know it was like people
out there got a drink in and you know
cuz there's a game making noise and I
was and then I just started filming like
the old man quiet down I was filming on
Instagram it's too loud out here what do
you do that guys for comedy you know how
many cities out there sake you know this
keep Portland weird
there's keep Austin weird yeah there's
another one that says keep something
weird with it I was just there well
there wasn't Vancouver somebody I was
just that they said keep it weird
it's just like they're all jumping on
that one yeah wasn't it Portland first I
think it was poor yeah Portland was the
first one that said they're keeping it
weird yeah like just hippie hippie stuff
I always just think annoying white
person I love Portland
I love poreless yeah I like all of those
places but I don't like I like weird too
but I don't like planned weird now
now any more than I like planned crazy
or planned
dangerous yeah you know yeah there's not
really the dangerous comic and make the
dangerous comic was the thing when I was
coming up oh really yeah because they
all wanted to be like Bill Hicks or like
that like that kind of Kennison Hicks
right and Pryor and all these guys
because they they pushed out like these
these things they put this stuff out
there that people had not heard yeah
yeah yeah yeah so then there was this
leather jacket smokers cigarette on
stage era in stand-up comedy where
everybody like which is why I feel bad
for younger comics because they so much
of this early [ __ ] is just on YouTube I
mean good lord I mean how the [ __ ] do
you ever outrun that stuff so like
pretty nothing on YouTube but I got a
tight no but like like my generation
everybody went through there a lot of
people anyways myself included you go
through your am I gonna be a Bill Hicks
type of guy yeah yeah am i that guy and
they're just like yeah well I don't like
to read so I don't think I'm that guy
like as much as I was taking the piss
out of that guy talking about the para
seguir I don't know what the [ __ ] is in
it so he be might be right
I don't [ __ ] know I I have no idea
but I do know this paying attention to
what's going on is a great way to be
depressed so what I just I don't know
like six seven years ago I just stopped
paying attention to [ __ ] that I can't
[ __ ] control yeah
my life became a lot smaller and a lot
happier and I know you kind of have to
know what the [ __ ] is going on out there
to a certain extent but like there's
something I don't know it's 24 hour news
networks and social media the least
amount of time you can spend on those I
feel like your happiness will go up at
least it does for me yeah yeah I don't
haven't had a TV in years so I don't
know what's gonna it's so funny and
you're in this [ __ ] business yeah I
know and you know people talk politics
with me all the time and I'm like dude
I'm trying to figure out where I'm gonna
go on stage tomorrow
I'm just like I'm killing it though man
you've been going out with [ __ ] Marin
you go out on the road with me if you
can
been doing some headlining dates I'm
seeing you're gonna [ __ ] hit dude and
you gotta hit [ __ ] hard and this is
the thing like and then you'll see all
of those doors they all yeah they all
[ __ ] open up but it's just like when
you're not what they're looking for oh
yeah you have to show them why you are
like yeah viable [ __ ] thing I'll tell
you it'd be great oh sorry [ __ ] you're
here do I care hope for this [ __ ]
staycation is and then just [ __ ] just
hit the ground running yeah first thing
I did was I went to both our cars they
[ __ ] reset the clocks oh yeah and
there yeah it's like a big [ __ ] thing
for me yeah right
then I [ __ ] the microwave you hit the
microwave next microwave I don't think I
did I just did mine I did the one in the
kitchen one yeah I literally have the
old digital clock I that used to wake me
up for my paper route I still [ __ ]
haven't you got that yeah some of the
buttons don't quite work I got to find
something that can fix it for me
that what's the grocery store yeah
because you know put on some pounds and
I want to get it off so like I got this
whole meal plan or whatever so I did go
and buy all this [ __ ] [ __ ] did
all of that came home cooked the [ __ ]
dinner got my daughter to bed all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] no [ __ ] tired of [ __ ] I
got to do this because I'm [ __ ]
I'm going to see a buddy tomorrow to get
my car looked at yeah that's gonna be
great get it wrapped you know I'm
getting a clear wrap oh it's so nuts
yeah so then they'll detail my car so it
looks totally clean then it's a clear
wrap over the yeah top of it and then if
anybody opens their door into it it
doesn't chip the [ __ ] paint oh man I
rather get my car waxed ever again I can
just walk and wash yeah all of that
shit's great tremendous it's great dude
man it's just like a bunch of [ __ ] on my
car I went over to the car wash the guy
just sprayed it down and and towel
drying it thing looks brand-new
yeah Wow
yeah I don't know I keep [ __ ] for a long
time dude
yeah yeah do you know like I'm only on
like I'm 51 gonna be 52 mm like my
fourth car that's like 700 motorcycles
cars I [ __ ] drive them into the
[ __ ] ground my first vehicle I got it
yeah I bought it in 85 I kept it until
90 feel it early burned down on the side
of the [ __ ] Road
my first part from high school yeah
Patriots bumper sticker yeah together we
win 1985 AFC champions and like my
buddies would sit there going to look at
that bumper sticker I remember when you
[ __ ] put that thing on yeah and then
I had a Ana Honda Accord I drove that
for like [ __ ] 10 years that's a great
car yeah I bought it used to but 188
cloth you know I had then like six or
seven years then I went back to New York
so I sold that then I didn't have a car
for a number of years from early 2000 to
2007 then I got the Prius Yeah right
200,000 miles on it no no no no that
thing no that that black one yeah no I
bought that brand new those no what do
you have on it I got hundred thousand or
something out of miles right yeah it's
got over on it
I drove that thing and then then I got
my Jaguar but I mean I bought an old
truck too like an antique if you count
that a classic I bought so let's see
let's see it's the truck the Accord the
Prius the Jack Oh Marius I'll do it I
[ __ ] this [ __ ] car I'll Drive that
thing forever I think about it is is a
[ __ ] car if you take care of it the
[ __ ] engine block is made out of like
steel it's it's not going anywhere no no
and we always rise back for it to ever
[ __ ] die if you'd taken care of it now
look if you [ __ ] back east and
there's rock salt and all that [ __ ]
that's a whole other [ __ ] thing but
if you take care of the thing you should
be able to drive it forever absolutely
right
yeah absolutely especially we're not
commuting every day a hundred miles each
way that's really kills your ride too
just non-stop commute yeah it does but
if you [ __ ] maintain the thing yeah
yeah it's really no excuse to now with
all those jiffy lubes and [ __ ] yeah
now that they've worked out all the bugs
that they have their checks and balances
can remember back in the day like one
guy wouldn't be [ __ ] the guy take the
oil on the other guy wouldn't and then
you [ __ ] drive away in the engine
would cease Oh many had to try to sue a
[ __ ] corporation in there was always
those [ __ ] guys I didn't put the oil
the oil plug in all the way oh man yeah
I'm going down a high five on my on my
motorcycle
all sudden my whole helmet everything
just covered in oil instantly just and I
almost crashed I couldn't see and I was
sliding in my own oil I pulled over
no I got no oil I'm on the five you know
there's no motorcycle oil at the gas
station I didn't know there was
something different oh yeah yeah these a
different oil you know I've used a
certain viscosity what are they
synthetics and it's like you know just a
different one than the car so then I I
get towed somewhere I miss my gig and
just like [ __ ] and the guy obviously it
was just I saw before I wrap this up
yeah tell people about when you thought
you had a stroke oh man I was I was at
that Albertsons right here in the
neighborhood
yeah I was just walking in it was the
weirdest feeling I've ever had in my
life I was walking in and then I took a
step and I remember saying like well I I
feel kind of weird and as I said I feel
kind of weird the left side of my body
just shut off completely shut off and I
just collapsed to the ground and and
then I kind of sat there for me like
well and then my left foot was numb and
my arm was kind of numb and then it kind
of went back to normal and I got up my
god what happened - cash register guys
grabbed me and they go dude you just you
just collapsed and I was like wow
and then I just thought I'll just go
home and they go dude you should go to
the hospital you just collapsed man and
so I went straight to see her cyanide
and I've waited in the waiting room for
four hours and they finally put me in
the MRI and then they said you had a
stroke this woman she came in she goes
you didn't have a stroke today looks
like you had an old stroke and I was
like what and then they shot me up with
some stuff and I went to sleep and then
two guys came in a couple hours later
and they go you didn't have a stroke
this is an old vein you got a herniated
disc in your neck and it popped out and
when it pops out you know hit your spine
and just shut you down and that was from
when you got hit by Thurman over from
the motorcycle yeah that lady who stole
the Escalade yeah I I you know every
five six months I'd kind of get this
pinched nerve kind of thing in my my
neck and one time it locked up my jaw
but I would go to acupuncture or you
know do some therapy you know like
stretching and [ __ ] and it would go away
but this time it just it didn't I get
another Deen favorite yeah the time you
were [ __ ] Odeon oh yeah I'm below and
Laurel Canyon oh man
I'm up there this is the 80s here are
the 80s and they got like a they got
like a
seriously the dude that we called him
the shopper he was a blow dealer and he
had an actual pyramid of blow he always
like to try to be like the Scarface
uh-huh and I never forgot it
Axl Rose was there it was like eight of
us and he was there playing on the piano
he played us November rain like wow and
then I went over and just did a giant
pile what year was this I guess it's 80
a you know then recorded the illusion
record right but they had that song
kicking around and then I went over and
just did a giant bump and my arm went
numb instantly and I went over to the
guy and I was like dude man you got it
you gotta call it amber it's my arms
numb he's like no way man we got all
this blow around and Axl's here and so
we can't have the cops up here you got
to ride it out his favorite thing you
got right all right he handed me a
bottle I never got it of Stoli and he
goes just start slamming on this dude
and come down and I was like huh and I
just went into the other room and I was
slamming on it and I was rubbing my arm
I was rubbing it like thing and this
will work this will make it come back
did you end up writing it out in a
closet I did I went into this like
walk-in closet and I was freaking out
and I was hitting the vodka right I was
just hitting it like huh god oh my god I
got photos too from that night there's a
great photo of me and Axl my eyes are
just banned just and and about an hour
later I remember I remember I said this
bill I got I was in there like oh god
you always find God immediately you know
oh god if you let me come down from this
I'll never do coke again right and like
about an hour later I came out of there
and I was like alright I feel better you
know you didn't do it I didn't do
another I know where I don't think I did
coke ever again after that it was kind
of probably the end who [ __ ] drug
users man Wow
like the [ __ ] stories like I laughed
my the reason why I'm laughing at that
is because how [ __ ] terrified I would
be this is no [ __ ] way
I just would ever [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
yeah ever I mean I'm from the Lin you
know Len Bias generation where it was
just the whole story was he did it one
time and he died yeah which course
wasn't not being the [ __ ] truth I
mean the first time you tried coke you
don't freebase it right no no I just
love that guy we can't this too many
drugs see you got to ride it out yeah I
didn't know you could ride it out with
your Odeon on heroin that's when
everybody just leaves oh yeah that's the
old one right like we're just hey we're
out of here that guy's [ __ ] blue but
you can't ride out it was nuts too honey
they'll give you OD on [ __ ] coke yeah
you can just ride it out
well it's like a small stroke you're
having you know like so much coke your
hearts ache so that doctor was right you
did have a joke but not yes not today
long time ago and a [ __ ] late 80s
ma'am and that's you know you know
what's weird too is how much [ __ ] you'll
just put up your nose you don't even
know who the people are you know let me
get a bump of that and then you know you
could be car cleaner so what about Van
Halen with that [ __ ] MTV winner they
they were giving him blow he goes he did
a [ __ ] bump off a David Lee's [ __ ]
pinky I know I mean no worries about
[ __ ] liability he never did blow
either the guy he'd never even done it
before that's you know oh my god the
veto I don't think I still don't think I
would have but if ever I was gonna do it
1984 yeah I mean you got to do it I
don't think
parents get mad at me I be like it's
[ __ ] Diamond Dave oh yeah what was I
supposed to do yeah yeah you gotta do
the blow
you have to oh man dude I was doing a
gig at the Fillmore and with Mark Ford
from the Black Crowes he told this story
on my podcast it was great and he was
sitting in with that my band and we were
getting ready to go on it goes hey man
you know anybody's got some chilly
weather let's recall it chilly weather I
love that one and then I said I think I
think that guy over there and the guy
came over and he gave him a key shot and
he's like his eyes are pouring out right
he goes
that wasn't coke man that was mad and
they announced us right then so he gets
on stage his eyes are pouring with water
he plays the gig of his life after the
show I got me I said I'm sorry I didn't
know you know and he goes that's alright
it smoothed out the mushrooms this guy
was on mushrooms without even us knowing
playing sold out Fillmore show and he
killed like he played a gig that like
you you you would think he was gonna die
after then what's the difference what's
what's a meth high meth high versus you
do like a piece the size of your
fingernail and you're up for like 24
hours it's like it's tweak city you're
just up back you know it's like super
super dust man I don't know so what
happened so it's not really a high you
just don't alert you're no you're just
high you're tweaking yeah I mean you're
clean and you're you're you're building
models you know I mean you're just not
your septic tank yeah but you would do
that if you were super drunk and then
you could just kind of level out the
booze and keep drinking I give your out
part in supposed it if you drink if
you're drinking you're done in four
hours yeah right I don't give a [ __ ] who
you are right unless you're drinking at
a slower pace than your tolerance which
why would you do that the whole thing is
it's like a race car you're pushing the
limit yeah you're trying to take that
turn
fast as you can so you're doing shots
are you doing all of that [ __ ] and go
[ __ ] who you can only go for four hours
yeah at a certain at game pace yeah I
mean I can [ __ ] sit there on a dock
and just sit there and sipping beers all
[ __ ] day but I mean if you're
drinking for hours you're done then you
do a bump of this and you could keep
going that was the point I see you
because it would level it out and then
you could keep drinking like the party
would never end
yeah especially if you're at like a
rehearsal room and you're playing music
and you just want to keep going you know
for the love of music yeah well anyways
dude I am so excited about this gig
because not only to get to play with all
those great play musicians the miked up
drums just sound [ __ ] unbelievable
yeah and you rocked it last time dude
you're playing with Nikki Sixx last time
it's one of the funniest things to think
you had posters of that guy and then
there you are there's that great video
footage of him you're looking over at
him
I forgot I start the song I'm so like
fired out that you're up there with him
oh yes hit the teeth so I'm all right
this is kicked in the teeth again and
then we're just standing there all of us
and Scott Ian looks at me guys it's you
I go yeah it is me dude Scott Ian
[ __ ] killed it that guy said [ __ ] it
you don't like yeah any I'd loved how
serious all those guys took it oh yeah
that was Steve Gorman going showing up
and just going you see that pointed at
all the empty seats because that's gonna
be [ __ ] carnage today and he was not
[ __ ] and then it's still like that's
one of the great like live drummers I've
ever seen
Oh Mike was what he did on your show so
if you guys are anywhere near Los
Angeles this Tuesday at the Avalon right
across from Capitol Records what is
there a name for the show the yeah it's
the bond it's got well for years I
called it the Church of Bon Scott
searchable it's what I called it for ye
you know this is the 40 year anniversary
of bon Scott's death 48 year anniversary
of back in black but we started this
back when we were kids me and Josh Z and
Billy Roe we were doing this as kids in
San Francisco oh you oh I didn't know
that oh yeah we've done this for years
and then when I moved to LA I didn't
really have like the the time or
whatever to do it and then once I was a
comedian and stuff I was like let's fire
that thing up again you know and it's so
cool yeah I mean that's how long we've
been doing it and that guy's solo Dallas
that brings the equipment the vent we've
got all the same equipment ac/dc uses
the vintage Marshalls the vintage ampeg
svt the the same guitars and Josh Z just
kills it and they're thinking all that
you know if if I ever get to meet Phil
Rudd oh yeah what I would ask other than
talk helicopters cuz he flies
helicopters yeah that's right right is I
always wondered what happened to that
[ __ ] amazing kit that he had on the
back and black that black sonar no it
was it wasn't black it was an all
natural wood oh oh that's right I got
the poster that's right it's natural
wood [ __ ] gorgeous more Tom's than
he's ever hit in his entire career yeah
I think it was it was like two floor
toms and it was either three or four on
the top yeah four up two down and then
he had the single bass and in the snare
drum anyway soon I I got I got to go to
bed yeah I gotta drive this [ __ ] car
out to that yeah I've been up since 4:30
thank you so much for putting me on it
dude man it's gonna be [ __ ] awesome
and I'm looking as looking as forward to
playing drums as I am doing the stand-up
because I got all this [ __ ] new [ __ ]
that's coming out and I got some new
bits
oh yeah and dude I might [ __ ] that's
coming out right now I'm just it's is as
I don't know what the word is it's just
[ __ ] I'm just being an idiot yeah
I'm having a great time and I feel like
this [ __ ] the the overcorrection has
kind of gone back to the middle yeah you
can have fun again on stage it's kind of
nice
yeah with of course you know all the
[ __ ] that we've learned over the last
few years you know that people weren't
talking about yeah yeah all that
[ __ ] I'm having the most [ __ ] fun
I was telling my wife that I was like I
was like I'm having more [ __ ] fun on
stage than I think I ever have
oh that's I mean I said that on the last
and that's like 35 years in right 30
years you say I'm not that 28 28 but
still man like you know to be digging it
that far in know it [ __ ] love it I
love it at ten years in they said things
I also love I've been going to smaller
places
yeah and just [ __ ] getting up on
stage you know it's a different thing
than actually going to a comedy club
yeah you know I reminds me of back in
the day when you had to get him yeah so
like it's me every night yeah no no no I
don't think I'm at I'm as good as I was
then I when I was when I when I had to
get people to like me
yeah so now you once people get to know
you then you go on in there it's yours
to lose yeah
yes opposed to like how the [ __ ] am I
gonna get these people yeah like I just
remember that feeling standing back
there just going like yeah that's what I
had my first name of my first special
why do I do this and that's what I would
be thinking why do I do this why did I
just [ __ ] you know I'm an inherently
a shy person why the [ __ ] did I pick
this job why the [ __ ] do I do this and
you know and then you just [ __ ] go up
there and what's so [ __ ] funny is
even if it sucks you just have this
great story to tell all you stand-up
comedian friends and it almost in a
weird way makes it worth it so anyway
then we can talk about that for a
[ __ ] hour anyway suit I'm really
looking forward to it I'm gonna practice
my ass off over the next [ __ ] 48
hours Brad so I don't [ __ ] it up anyway
yeah
coming to the rehearsal tomorrow yes I
am very good I just got to get the
address and then Tuesday night tickets
at Dean del Rey calm
there you go and there's about 90 left
how cool yeah it's about 90 left so
we're gonna sell it yeah he'll it out
and awesome I'm telling you guys this is
the last one to man it's been so much
work to do this so and the people that
are playing I'm like you're never gonna
do this again I don't know man it's so
it's a bad time to ask right now that's
like asking some are you gonna host the
Oscars again I'm trying to put together
the [ __ ] monologue so much yeah Meryl
is like what do you mean man it's like a
month of work and then like it's great
yeah I'm like yeah but bad dude it's
[ __ ] it's right now look if I was at
a level where I could just sell out the
Avalon on my own I would do it every
year
I'd be like just show up see me so
there's gonna be more yeah that's all
all right love you brother thanks for
coming on I'll see you tomorrow with the
at the rehearsal all right that's it
I'll check in on you guys on Thursday